attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
vous allez bien je reviens de la corse
sucreries on est partis au club j'ai
fourie comme un cochon vous n'êtes pas
parti d'une autre femme
c'est ici mais pendant qu'elle faisait
la sieste j'ai des gouver la moitié du
village d il ya même eu un mec est c'est
les vacances
bah oui au moins mes vacances je n'étais
plus là intérieur de pas me raconte pas
ma faute a dû partir en province
alors je me suis gavé de fruits de mer
et si marrant tu vois pas ce que le
homard au bout de quinze jours qui
sature un peu comme moi ça me fait
pareil avec le surimi
au bout de quatre journées marge de
stature et c'est ça qui est bon avec
vous les pauvres à plat de taboulé
humble et sangria et et voûté 15 jours
et j'ai regardé ton instagram ça avait
l'air chouette des vacances avec ta
copine
non mais ça c'est pour rendre jaloux
ceux qui partent pas à nous on voit on
est huit jours de pluie c'est pour ça
j'ai pris toutes les photos même jour et
après je les ai posté en décalé nous
alors on s'est éclaté avec jean-pierre
alors là c'est quand on était au bord de
la mer avec les enfants là c'était le
jour on a mangé une glace
là c'est au bailliage tu vas monter tous
tes photos relou comme ça maintenant
avec trois là on vient première de ces
kilos petit cul l'un à la sacema dies
charlotte et à d'autres photos de
charlotte à la plage abat sur moi tant
battue s'est coiffé - dossier tous les
envoie par mail à tout de suite celle là
celle là tac
ceci aussi est ac
métabief prix soleil carrément un dans
la gueule mais tu as bien pris le soleil
ah ouais j'ai confondu lotion anti
moustiques et la crème solaire du coup
pas de piqûre mais deux jours nos
relations
les remarques ce qui est très bien avec
le rouge c'est du coup on voit moins ton
acné ouais mais j'ai chopé une meuf une
moche bon ça bosse ici on m'a demandé de
l'argent parce que moi j'ai déjà réservé
mon bateau pour l'été prochain
ah oui nadine toyer pourquoi vous
m'envoyer des photos d'une petite boule
à moitié à poil
non ça c'est pour moi ça doit de le
transférer patron pervers
[Musique]